- It came true.
(audience clapping)
This means so much more to me this time.
I don't know why, I think the first time
I hardly felt it because
it was all so new.
I wanna say thank you
to you, I haven't had
an Orthodox career and I
wanted more than anything
to have your respect.
The first time I didn't
feel it but this time
I feel it.
(audience clapping)
(maniacal laughing)
Oh, thank you, thank you ever so much.
I'm, and sir you're doing a great job
but you're so quick with that stick
so why don't you sit cause
I may never be here again,
I can't believe this, this is so,
so quite pretty.
I want to acknowledge
so many people that made
Erin Brokovich Erin
Brokovich but first let me
adjust my dress.
This movie was sinfully fun to make
and turn off that clock,
it's making me nervous.
Steven Soderberg, hi!
(audience clapping)
Oh my god, oh come on, all right, okay.
Thank you so much, thank you, thank you.
When they called my
name I had this feeling
I could hear half of America going oh no,
come on her, why,
her, again, you know, and whatever.
I really want to thank all my colleagues,
all my friends.
I look out here and you know I see my life
before my eyes.
(audience clapping)
I'm gonna cry because this show has been
as long as my career.
(audience laughing)
I have wondered for 26 years
what this would feel like,
thank you so much for
terminating the suspense.
He is at work with everyone,
God bless that principle,
God bless that potential that we all have
for making anything possible
if we think we deserve it.
I deserve this, thank you.